le raffinement à fleur de peau un
privilège de femmes
[Musique]
et oui il était temps pour les
fabricants de s'intéresser au dessous de
l'homme c'est ce que fait nico c'est un
créateur d'origine grecque qui en 17
mois et deux saisons a révolutionné le
sous-vêtement son pari proposé une ligne
haut de gamme c'est cela coûte au
minimum 200 francs une ligne classique
et pure
et ça marche sa boutique est désormais
envahis par les acheteurs italiens
allemands ou américains
je pense qu'il fonde tout cela
correspondait vraiment une nécessité de
l'homme actuel donc sec explique
vraiment les succès mondial avec des
cinq points de vente au monde et cent
mille pièces les premières années le
mahb est vraiment besoin s'il voulait
renouveler s'éteignait intime surtout
parce que ces normes sur les qui bouge
énormément il fera dans les salles de
gym
c'était donc cibler que se trouve très
souvent en sous vêtements
depuis que les publicités déshabille le
sexe fort et à l'heure où les femmes
choisies sur pièce les marques grand
public aussi se lance dans la lingerie
pour hommes
[Musique]
d'où il
on utilise désormais des matières nobles
la soie notamment et la couleur et
rennes et certains fabricants comme gil
n'hésite pas à organiser des défilés
pour lancer une nouvelle gamme dans un
marché stable dominé par les
importations en provenance d'europe et
d'asie les fabricants français pour ne
pas s'endormir joue la carte de
l'imagination de sous vêtements
masculins et les halls pour plus avoir
peur d'abord d'acheter les
sous-vêtements de s'y intéresser et
pour moi c'est important de dire que les
sous vêtements ne se cachent plus leur
verse montre et ce monde d'une façon ou
sexy ou humoristiques
les 2sous ne se cache plus soit mais
allons plus loin proclame jean paul
gaultier qui bouscule les normes et
propose la mode sans dessus dessous
[Musique]
collant tandja tel caleçon dentelle
seraient alors les attributs de l'homme
fin de siècle quand les deux sous se
porteront dessus
[Musique]